*il s'amuse a taper sur la camera*
*Musique sympa*
Ça va?
Les amis aujourd'hui
On va jouer au jeu VR qui a le plus buzzer cette année 'fin l'année dernière
Du coup en 2017 C'est VR chat c'est un jeu dans lequel
on va pouvoir choisir notre avatar, on vas pouvoir aller de monde en monde
Et rencontrer d'autres joueurs et leur parler
Et peut-être ensuite se voir dans la vraie vie
Boire un verre
Vraiment créer une amitié durable
Tout ça grâce à du virtuel
C'est magnifique !
En gros, c'est un peu un site de rencontres nouvelle génération
Où tu vois les gens dans le jeu, MAIS ils ont choisit un avatar
Donc ils restent anonymes
J'ai vu milles trucs sur ce jeu
J'ai toujours eu trop envie d'y jouer mais j'ai jamais fait le pas parce qu'il faut parler anglais
Vu que c'est des gens qui viennent du monde entier
Donc pour que tout le monde puissent se comprendre, faut parler anglais !
Vous connaissez mon skill en anglais
Vous en faites pas je suis allé 48 heures à Londres avec mon frère
Il y a 3 jours
Donc normalement tout va bien se passer
C'est parti !
*démelage de fil en cours*
Alors ! Premièrement on va choisir ensemble l'avatar
Donc là on ressemble à ça
J'aimerais bien qu'on ait un truc un peu plus original
Genre un biker
Regarde . Aaaaah !
On est mieux ou pas ? ( nope )
ça c'est excellent
OK, je vois mes jambes, je vois mes mains et je peux changer les expressions de mes mains en fait
Je peux faire 2, je peux faire ça  *mouvement* et un pouce... Voilà!
Donc on entend les autres gens dans le jeu et eux, nous entendent aussi
Et on se déplace avec le joystick
Et en fait quand on se déplace on se voit se déplacer
Voilà.
Et quand j'arrête
Hop
Je me retrouve à l'endroit où mon avatar était
V'Voyez ?
Hop! Voilà c'est tout! C'était l'explication la plus simple et la plus efficace.
Ensuite, tu choisis le monde dans lequel tu vas
Ya une chiée de mondes !
"The Great Pug" Je crois que ça c'est LE monde de base je crois c'est un pub il me semble
*Fffou*. Toutes les ressources de mon cerveau sont disponible pour parler Anglais
*pet gênant* Ah
c'est stressant
Ouuh charmant!
*Vent..*
*Musique triste de guitare*
*MUSIQUE TRISTE DE GUITARE*
Vous vous moquez de moi et vous partez?!
Mec c'est trop bien par ce que ce système la pour te déplacer ne te donne pas la gerbe
donc c'est un vrai plaisir
ok .
AHAHA!
Ah !
Qu'est ce que? AHAHAHAH
Anna :'( *Pleure comme un beau comédien*
*Musique triste de violon*
Ahah c'est trop bien le mec c'est un guide!
Alors c'est quoi le Void Club j'suis curieux
Aaaaaaah il y a de la musique!
*Il danse* Oui oui oui .
C'est chiant.
On va aller à la chambre des présentations
(Le début du WTF)
Regarde c'est génial!
Oh nan il s'en va!
Le pauvre jl'ai fait quitter le jeu mec!
Jvais le traquer dans tout VR Chat!
Je veux toucher des tétons!
"Avatar Testing" tiens c'est un monde dans lequel ils testent des avatars. On va aller voir ça.
(Yaoi)
Comment j'cours y a un bug c'est incroyable!
Où ce jeu va nous mener mec?
AU CLAIR DE LA LUNE, MON AMI PIERROT *il crie*
*atchoum* *reniflement dégueulasse*
*VIOLENCE*
Aaah j'lai fait quitter le pauvre!
Aller jvais faire chier d'autre gens j'adore!
Oh un monde dans le Japon c'est bon ça!
*Rire démoniaque*
Squeezie?!
Salut ça va?
On fait une rencontre abonnés dans VR Chat?
Bah oui ça va
Goku viens me faire un câlin avant que j'aille dans un autre monde. Viens me faire un câlin viens là
Ben en tout cas c'était un plaisir de te rencontrer
Bah écoute pareil mec, j'te fais de gros bisous
Et bisou à Natsu hein
Ouai! Haha tchao poto
Je me fait stalker
C'est toi qui me stalk ! Non
Sii tu me suis dans les mondes où je vais j't'ai entendu dire "Coupe ton micro j'enregistre"
Tu me stalk! Tu me stalk dans VR Chat mec c'est incroyable!
T'as dis à ton pote de couper son micro!
Mais vous êtes fous! Mais laissez moi!
*Bisous*
ça a aucun sens !
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur VR Chat!
J'crois que j'ai jamais tourné aussi longtemps!
Réellement jcrois que sa fait 3 heures que je tourne j'ai pas vu le temps passer!
Y'a des situations improbables, tu TOMBES sur des trucs improbables
Réellement mec c'est trop drôle tu fais des rencontres improbables!
C'est GÉNIAL!
Moi j'adore découvrir des gens, d'ailleurs sur le monde
Enfin bon j'ai trop kiffé! Tout simplement voilà!
Et les voir dans le jeu comme si ils étaient vraiment là j'trouve ça vraiment génial!
NIPPES !!